and we are live hello happy Monday
everybody I'm answering a quick question
from somebody in my mastermind group who
was talking about how do you promote
yourself when you're a subcontractor and
this happens a lot with entrepreneurs
where you know you have your own
business but you may work through
partners you may be under somebody
else's business at times when you are
getting started or even as you're
growing bigger even now I do a lot of
work under agencies so I work with a lot
of brands but I'll get connected through
an agency instead of it being directly
through me and so there's always a
little bit of worry as to how do you
promote yourself best is it right to say
that you have your own business as well
or not and I wanted to share a few
strategies my master I remember what
she's going through is she does
copywriting and she's working on some
sales pages with somebody and he's off
selling and when bringing her in to help
her with with the copywriting so a
couple points 1 I would see what they're
comfortable with because the most
important relationship with all of this
is you with the company that you're
working with not the final client but
the person who is outselling you and so
it's see how comfortable are they in you
talking about your business you
mentioned that you're an entrepreneur as
well or not you're going into
relationship being a subcontracted brand
for them and so some people are super
open to it and they don't care if you
also mention your name and what you're
up to and some people are very
protective over their client base and
don't want that to happen at all and so
I wouldn't want you to risk losing that
kind of relationship and I would be open
and honest with the person that you're
talking to and see what they want right
under saying what they're comfortable
with the second thing is to understand
what the follow-up is and that's where a
lot of people that you end up working
with the end client well then want more
work right so you help them with with a
landing page that's great you help them
with the sales copy awesome they may say
wow what she did was really great I want
to hire them back to do more work and so
then it becomes an issue of who does
that work go through and still go
through the company you're contracted
with or are they allowed to contact you
right away
and again it's understanding that
relationship with the company that
you're dealing with your friend who
hired you what happens with future work
if the client wants to do more work who
does it go through is it okay to do more
work or not and again I'd always make
sure that it's okay with my friend but
the guy who brought me in before ever
talking to the customer about future
projects and then the last one is does
it help you to promote them as well you
know if you are just getting started up
when you're not a brand name and people
don't know you sometimes it can help you
to have their name their logo their
credentials on your website on your
business cards on your videos on your
mark material and so I'd be looking at
this company that you're working with
does their name add more leverage to
what you're doing or not you know maybe
not if you're associated with this big
agency then maybe that helps you go and
get new clients to say oh well they
choose worked with this person but if
they're just a small person as well and
they're not that well-known then I'd
recommend going off with your own brain
and so those are my quick thoughts in
terms of how to promote yourself when
you are a subcontractor on a job I've
had to do a lot of times working with
brands and agencies and also to the
salsa dancing business that I have a lot
of the instructors that that will hire
will be subcontract so that's
subcontracted I'm so I'd love to know
what you guys think youtube world leave
a comment below if you are a
subcontractor if you hire subcontractors
what's the relationship and how do you
promote yourself or loud then promote
themselves and for those of you
interested in joining our online
mastermind group i'll leave the link in
description thank you guys have a great
day